we're looking at a Health Service that
has
47 47
000 nurses missing about 10 000 doctors
in secondary care we have uh again
missing we've got one thousand fewer GPS
than we had when they first made the
target to increase our GP numbers by 6
000 we've got a growing patient load we
know that that impacts the care that we
can provide and at the same time as
we've had a pandemic we've had massive
inflation we've had a real terms pay cut
of over a quarter for junior doctors
over a third for consultants and nurses
facing similar
so of course we have to take action in
that circumstance because we're not
happy with with either the the squeeze
and our living standards that we've been
forced to endure and nor with the impact
that that's having on the care that
we're able to provide would you like to
see coordinated
um action amongst the uh Health Service
unions we know that the nurses are
planning to go uh on strike I think on
the 15th
um of December when I was speaking to
Unison yesterday their leader suggesting
that potentially ambulance drivers could
could coordinate with nurses is that
something that you support
certainly we'll be having those
conversations Junior doctors are
palleting on the 9th of January and so
it will be a while before doctors are
joining joining any coordinated action
but there are two reasons to coordinate
and the first in the Health Service is
to make sure that patients are safe and
we obviously work as a team across the
health service so if we don't coordinate
and discuss amongst ourselves how we're
going to cover urgent emergency and
critical care and that then we will we
will have problems so we we do need to
do some degree of coordination and the
second reason is that we want there to
be an impact on the employers and on the
government to bring them to the table to
negotiate with us and if we coordinate
and if we're effective the government
and employers will negotiate faster and
that's better for us and better for
patients in the long term so
coordination is not bad news for
patients or the public coordination is
good news for for patients and the
public as well as for us as unions and
and staff in the Health Service